عندما تم رفع العلم فوق
السفارة الأمريكية في هافانا لأول مرة منذ
أكثر من 50 عامًا
، لم يكن ذلك بمثابة استئناف
للعلاقات الدبلوماسية الكوبية الأمريكية
فحسب ، بل كان أيضًا بمثابة تتويج لإنجاز السياسة الخارجية
للرئيس آنذاك باراك
أوباما ،
لقد جئت إلى هنا لدفن  آخر
بقايا من الحرب الباردة في الولايات المتحدة ،
حيث ثبت أن التفاؤل كان مجرد أمنيات
قبل وقت قصير من مغادرة أوباما لمنصبه ، وكان
بعض الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين ، وبعضهم من ضباط المخابرات السرية ،
قد بدأوا
يمرضون في ظروف غامضة ، وكان أكثرهم
تأثرًا بإصابات دماغية قاموا
بفحصهم ، كما قال العديد
من الأمريكيين.  أبلغت وزارة الخارجية عن سماع
أصوات غريبة وأصبحت الحوادث
معروفة
باسم الهجمات الصوتية في خريف عام 2017
، وسحبت وزارة الخارجية عائلات الدبلوماسيين والموظفين غير الأساسيين
تاركين طاقم هيكل عظمي في السفارة التي
أعيد افتتاحها حديثًا بعد أكثر من ثلاث سنوات.
لا يمكن التقدم بطلب للحصول على تأشيرات في
السفارة تاركًا أشخاصًا مثل المنتصر
الذي يأمل في السفر إليها  نحن
لعلاج شكل نادر من السرطان
تقطعت به السبل ،
كانت الإجابة التي حصلنا عليها هي أنهم لم يتمكنوا من
تلقي الطلب لأن
القنصلية كانت مغلقة ، كما يقول ،
على الرغم من أنها حالة طبية ، إلا
أن مصالحنا لا يتم تقديمها بشكل
كبير.  التغييرات جارية في كوبا ، كانت هناك
احتجاجات غير مسبوقة من قبل
الفنانين ضد الرقابة ،
وتخفف الحكومة الكوبية القيود المفروضة على
رواد الأعمال من القطاع الخاص
، ومن المتوقع أن يتنحى رال كاسترو
في أبريل عن رئاسة الحزب الشيوعي للجزيرة ،
لكن في الوقت الحالي لا
يوجد أي حضور دبلوماسي لنا تقريبًا
في هذه الجزيرة ، أعلنت إدارة بايدن
أنها تراجع
قرار تقليص عدد موظفي السفارة ، لكن
سبب مرض الدبلوماسيين
قد لا يُعرف أبدًا ، أشارت دراسة أصدرتها
الأكاديمية الوطنية للعلوم
في ديسمبر / كانون الأول إلى
إمكانية تركيز طاقة الميكروويف
كسبب محتمل.
سرعان ما رفض محققو كوبا أنه لا يوجد احتمال مادي
س  يخترق سلاح الميكروويف
غرف الفنادق
ويسبب تلفًا في الدماغ دون حرق
الجلد
ودون الإضرار بأنسجة أخرى ، أشارت
مراجعة رفعت عنها السرية من 2018
حصل عليها أرشيف الأمن القومي
إلى أن
المسؤولين الحكوميين الأمريكيين
أخفقوا في التحقيق الأولي
في الهجمات
حتى بعد عام ونصف.  كل هذا
بدأنا
نحن المحققون لم يكن لدينا
فكرة غامضة عما حدث إذا حدث أي شيء
أه في كوبا والتقرير
يوضح ذلك تمامًا محامي ثمانية
من الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين
يخبرون CNN أن موكليه ما زالوا يشعرون
بآثار ذلك-  تسمى متلازمة هافانا حتى لو
قررت إدارة بايدن إرسال
مسؤولين آخرين ليحلوا محلهم ، قد لا يتم حل
لغز كيف مرض الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين في
كوبا
باتريك أبمان
سينا هافانا